so I'm going to talk to you about
something that I actually got to debut
here at this event last year and it's
something that I'm pretty passionate
about having been a real fan of
typography for a really long time unable
to really do much with that on the web
for a very long time so I've tried to
put this in in some terms that will be
most relevant to all of us as web
professionals but also tie back to some
important ideas about typography and how
it can actually really shape and
influence the message that we try and
get across so we'll talk about some
dragons will talk about graphic design
and we'll talk about a few other crazy
things that that we all get to work with
on a daily basis two weeks ago I was at
a type design conference up in Montreal
actually I'm from just outside
Providence Rhode Island so up is here to
me and saying that in front of a bunch
of people who have like collectively
centuries of experience designing type
gave me a little bit of angst here it
just sounds kind of odd but I think
what's important for me is when I talk
about web typography it's very specific
it's not general typography it actually
has some very specific connotations and
constraints that are relevant to us
building digital products and platforms
so I think to explain some of those
concepts better we'll go back to the
people you know the reason why people
actually know who I am
which is the guy that walks Tristan on
the left but Tristan now has a pal
hanging out with him her name's Tilly we
adopted her back in January she's
actually a Tristan's cousin
Tristan's nine we've had him since he
was about four months old completely
adorable but I thought that because of
their differences in size it might give
me a good way to talk to you about some
typographic terms like width or weight X
height or Flint
those are all terms that are relevant to
describing the type that you're putting
on screen and they so happen to tie into
the things that you can vary in a
variable font among others so most of
the web is words it's the stuff that I'm
going to be talking about variable cat
videos would be different and one of the
things that I tend to do is spend a lot
of time on our morning walks kind of
thinking about those differences between
regular and web typography and and how
this impacts what we do and how I can
explain the value of type in the context
of how we build performant web systems
and think back to what we've learned
about typography so far so going back
hundreds and hundreds of years to the
way things were created by by monks back
in the 14th century or when things
started to get printed on a press there
was a lot of skill and attention to
detail that went into conveying the
message that the word spell out coming
forward again into some of the details
that we see in the in the printed book
this is a copy of Moby Dick illustrated
by Rockwell Kent we have this really
beautiful initial capital from Keith
Houston's book about book design initial
capital section marks that sort of
emphasized first word these are all ways
to amplify the message and start to
bring people into a story in a way that
is more than just the letters on the
page another couple of things that I
really enjoyed in this book with notice
how the F and the I connect together in
that ligature where they've got this
separate style for the first paragraph
from them from the rest what helps bring
you into that narrative proper quotation
marks that's something that has been a
solved problem on the web for a while
and unfortunately is not something that
a lot of people really put some thought
into implementing those fixes so you end
up seeing some things that really kind
of run counter to that and undo it in
ways that are kind of disappointing but
this phrase is something that really
resonates to me in
and when I tweeted this a couple weeks
ago I was really surprised and happy
with the reaction that that got from
people and it ended up getting retweeted
quite a bit and every time we just say
yeah it's alright it'll be fine
we sort of peel away a little bit of
that veneer a little bit of that polish
about how we communicate and because
we're communicating so much more
frequently in digital platforms and
ebooks and websites and mobile apps
we're in danger of losing all of the the
power and sophistication of
communication that we have been learning
and and refining over the past five six
hundred years since we started actually
printing things on paper this was a an
article online of course and on the
Atlantic web site back in December of
last year and you see this all the time
in the US there's a morning NBC news
show called The Today Show and in their
lower third and the graphics they have
these straight up and down hash marks
for quotations all the time and it
really drives me nuts I mean there's
been a module for Drupal out there and
I'll plug in for a wordpress that
actually fixes this that's been around
for almost 10 years you turn it you turn
it on and it just works it fixes your
apostrophes and your quotation marks and
and it gives you proper typography we
don't have to be lazy about this so I go
back to Turner reservoir take a few more
deep breaths and start to think about
how we can just educate people a little
bit more to build these things into
their frameworks it doesn't have to be
something that you start from scratch
every time so it starts with defining
what good typography is and working with
a designer working with somebody or just
yourself going and reading up on it a
little bit trying to decide what are the
things that matter so things like
quotation marks proper hyphenation
OpenType features like ligatures or
those proper fractions things like that
or initial capitals those are all nice
features of typography you don't have to
use them all the time but they're all
things that are pretty easy to implement
and implement in a sustainable way that
work every time you add new content so
there are things that don't require
adding additional classes to your markup
and all that sort of thing so get a good
framework in place and it always just
kind of works now the talk is about
variable fonts not just about what you
decide is good typography but that's
really sort of the the first dragon that
I think is worth slaying is the fact
that there's a whole bunch of people in
this room and I'm willing to wager if I
ask how many of you studied graphic
design there's not gonna be a ton of
hands that go up anybody that's actually
more than I was expecting and that's
awesome so the people that studied
graphic design are very much in the
minority in the web design world because
a lot of people just kind of find their
way in it's a really open community it's
fantastic that way but without that
understanding of what is typography how
do you set type together how do you come
up with a good readable line length
what's a good distance between lines of
type those things you have to learn
along the way what we want to do is
actually make sure that everyone has
that baseline level of education about
how to work with type and make sure that
we can figure out what we can do what we
can control and what we can so when I
started working on the web it looked a
little different than it does now so
some of the things like this that's
pretty much what the first web pages
that I worked on looked like because
back in 1994 that's all you could do it
was gonna be x at the time there wasn't
even an aerial yet it was just whatever
was installed on the user system
eventually things got really fancy and
we were able to put a maximum width and
then start to specify some other
typefaces so we're starting to implement
a little bit of greater readability and
typographic techniques and we eventually
got to the point where we could use web
fonts and start to incorporate finer
touches in typography that really helped
kind of develop a more sophisticated
visual system and this another sample
page that I worked on that
shows things like those nice initial
caps the ligatures proper citation
excuse me
knew that was going to happen proper
quotation marks few other things like
those little the hyphenation the section
marks the initial first line in the the
line of text after the section mark
those are all touches that can be built
into your CSS so that every time you
flow a new copy like whether it's in
WordPress or Drupal or any other content
management system all of those things
are inherited and there are also things
that can be then selectively overwritten
for example in German where the
hyphenation dictionaries aren't as good
you can turn off the hyphenation there
so these are all things to think about
in developing a good typographic system
in a more sustainable way and also think
about what that mobile experience is
going to be like so this is another
thing that I've written about and talked
about quite a bit is tailoring the size
of your headings in relation to the body
copy based on screen size really helps
convey the importance but also maintain
readable line lengths and a nicer more
tailored experience on the small screen
so this is all different renderings of
different screen size shots of the exact
same page so we can create a good
typographic system but the problem is
that requires an awful lot of font files
because every single one of those
different widths and weights is a single
different file that has to be loaded so
this is dragon number two performance
because inevitably what happens whenever
a designer comes in with this beautiful
design the developer is going to look at
that and say you're loading 14 font
files it's going to be a massive
download there's no way this is going to
fit in our performance budget this has
to go and honestly rightly so I'm maybe
not completely but it really is
irresponsible to overload a page with a
ton of font files when you could convey
the message in an interesting and
compelling manner with fewer of them as
long as you're keeping that in mind
during the design process so things like
this are really important
to keep in mind because you'll if you
have been doing a lot of development
that has anything to do with web fonts
you'll know that three seconds is an
important number because quite often if
a web browser is waiting around for web
fonts to load it doesn't show any
content at all for guess what three
seconds
you just lost half your audience waiting
for those fonts to load so there is a
real problem in balancing the
availability of the fonts can getting
the design right and then still having
an experience show up so to do that page
I through every single weight and
variant of open sans in there that I
could find
it's 549 Kay that was about 18 files now
it made for a nice variety and visual
language but it certainly doesn't make
for a quality experience for the end
user when they're on a small mobile
device waiting for all this stuff to
download on a crappy connection on the
subway all of those things are very
normal real-world things so this is what
happens we pare back the design we
simplify things we load fewer files a
lot of people may look at the difference
between those two and think that's fine
and in some cases maybe it is but we've
lost a little bit of our voice and a
little bit of the differentiation that
we might otherwise be able to achieve so
there's a balance here that needs to be
struck this is a really important number
variable fonts substitute all of those
different font calls with a single file
maybe two that's a real number open sans
served over 26 billion times last week
think about that amount of bandwidth
across that network I mean that's kind
of amazing to think how much is being
served there now on average there's one
or two on a given page but it also could
just as easily be a lot more but also
think about if it's Google web fonts
it's going to be cached when you're
loading it from the same CDN all over
the place so you the user might see open
sans on five different sites and you
could conceivable
loading one file so that's a better
experience for you and saves a few bucks
for somebody who was serving the file so
last year three weeks before I came here
at a type I in Warsaw a type and
typography conference the variable font
format was introduced really kind of
blew my mind as a designer and a fan of
good performance on the web seeing what
those implications are and immediately
started thinking about how I might be
able to incorporate that in what I was
talking about thinking about and and
speaking about so I got the demo
literally two nights before I came here
looked at some stuff on stage it was
really fun it didn't actually catch on
fire so I was even better and so this is
getting into looking at see in this case
that is normal page loading 26 files so
this is using s on 600k to get that
whole layout change that over to LaVette
from CJ done it's an experimental font
that he's working on in the variable
format two files that's kind of Awesome
so thinking about all of that being
produced the italic is one file the
Roman is the other that beautiful
display and the initial cap and the body
copy is coming from the same file all
we're doing is changing the weight
changing the width that's it it's really
kind of amazing what you can do with it
and it's all controllable via CSS and
animatable to buy it so that's kind of
awesome we've sort of dealt with our
design language and the expansion of our
vocabulary in addition to dealing with
performance all with this one
improvement so that's really pretty
remarkable and that's not even the whole
story because we can also do things like
in this page where we start to play
around back
for a second so on this page this one is
typeset in gimlet from David Jonathan
Ross so it's another one that has a
number of different axes of variation so
that's replaced everything that we had
in the previous version with just a
single file and that's I think the
current file size that I've gotten from
him for this was about 40k now that's
not everything I mean I still have some
work to do
I imagine that you'll see really good
ones in the 5200 K range with a number
of different axes of variation and all
the open type features and things like
that
but when you think about what that's
replacing that's a pretty powerful 100 K
that you might be downloading if you can
replace so much other stuff and so to
give you a more visual explanation of
what's going on sorry with these if you
watch this animation this is actually
recorded out of a browser this is on the
axis practice website and I'll have a
link to that later on where you can kind
of play around with this stuff a little
bit so that's just animating through a
bunch of different axes of variation in
that one file right in a web browser
this is something that's tremendously
powerful now that I'm sort of
paraphrasing something from about 80
years ago about type being the clothes
our words wear but think about how much
more you can say when that clothing can
be anything you want in your wardrobe so
it does bring us to a third thing to
consider and any Game of Thrones fans
out there know you can't forget the
third dragon it was much better when I
gave this talk when it was actually on
the night of the finale few weeks ago
that really got some laughs and so
because this can be tailored with CSS we
can do some pretty interesting things
based on screen size so that's that same
page in the small screen view using
standard fonts and then we kind of play
around this a little bit with gimlet
and if you've noticed as this gets
smaller those characters are getting
narrower and I have some other examples
of this too when you take a look at Moby
Dick here notice in German on the right
hand side look at the the rag on the
right down there there's a lot of gaps
and it looks a little a little uneven
maybe a little bit hard to read because
the words in German are just on average
about 40 percent longer than they are in
English on a small screen typically you
only get between 30 and 40 characters
per line so it makes for a somewhat
choppy reading experience well if we
narrow those characters just slightly
it's not that perceptible from a
readability standpoint you're really not
making it harder for people to read but
you just added about 10 characters per
line so I did something in English
giving you a longer line length that
makes for a smoother reading experience
and in German it also evened out the rag
on the right so that it just gave a more
aesthetic appearance as well that's
pretty powerful that's an interesting
thing that you can do and there's also
something you know if you notice that
shift it got a little bit more contrast
II we modified the grade so the grade of
the text is the thickness of the strokes
and the characters and by altering the
grade you can increase the contrast
between foreground and background
without reflowing the text so think
about that in ambient light lower
ambient light you can automatically
increase the contrast on the text or
provide a UI control for people with low
vision so we can address a lot of
interesting accessibility concerns with
this as well so becoming device and
context aware and reactive to individual
users needs really challenges the notion
of what typography is and takes it quite
a bit further and I think that's really
one of the most compelling things about
this is that it really yes we can design
more and we can have a freer level of
expression and it loads faster and those
are all great things but making a
compelling individualized experience I
think that's really powerful and really
fascinating to see where we can go with
that so
we've chained up our dragons we've kind
of solved a lot of stuff and that's
pretty awesome but I did mention the the
whole future thing so I don't want to
forget that there's still something more
and and that's really worth talking
about and take a look at these news
sites so I'm gonna go through a few
different ones here and I'm willing to
wager that you won't really be able to
identify more than one or two of them
and these are the top eight or so news
websites in the world so what's happened
is that we've spent all our time
optimizing our process to design
Universal layout and typographic systems
for these large-scale content management
environments and we can pump any content
we want in the world in there and they
just work and it really kind of takes
the individuality out of it whereas if
we go back to what these monks were
working on they didn't go with good
enough
that was never okay typography is about
more than that it's about design it's
about communication and it's about
intentionality it's about making
conscious decisions about not just any
content but also this specific content
that's a really important distinction so
we go back and look at some newspapers
in print and look at all the different
sizes and shapes of lettering they're
using to give you cues about what is
important and where does the hierarchy
of these stories to get your attention
around that printed page you can see it
again over here and here and here so all
of these different typographic styles
have a reason for being
they're about guiding your attention to
the top story and then the next one and
then the next one and there's a very
clear intentionality to it based on very
specific headlines not just any headline
so why not get graphic design back in
the room instead of thinking about it
just purely at the beginning before
you've ever put any content into the
system let's think about how might we
bring design back in later in the
process
because what happened before is yes
somebody would write some text there
would be an editor and then a designer
would lay it out and that's how you get
these really remarkable print layouts
they're really quite beautiful
what ended up happening on the web was
we turned things around because it's so
hard to keep up with putting content on
the web we had to create things and
systems and that does make a lot of
sense but it's not the only thing that
we should be concerning ourselves with
so this is great to create that system
one system for everything it's not so
great for creating really unique
compelling content so why don't we turn
it around again we've got variable fonts
that are being loaded so it's a single
asset maybe two and we have a content
management system how might we think
about bringing those things together
Jason santamaría
did this experiment Jason santamaría did
this experiment a few years ago where he
decided he wanted to art direct each
blog piece and they're absolutely
beautiful and incredibly unique and
completely unsustainable there's no way
he could keep up with it so he gave up
and he went back to a different design
it was really unfortunate but also
completely understandable
ProPublica also does a really beautiful
job typesetting and designing specific
layouts for specific articles but they
too end up having to hit a reset button
every time they want to publish a story
like this they literally have to check a
button in the content management system
that says don't load anything from the
content management system here's your
HTML and CSS and it's brilliant and and
just crushingly disappointing all at the
same time because that's not what the
system should be about the system should
be supporting the design flexibility not
circumventing it so I wanted to think
through how we might be able to do that
a little bit better since we have these
tools at our disposal we could think
about something a little bit different
so what if in our content management
system we could highlight some text hit
a button just like we do with making
something bold and decide how bold or
modify other axes so if we hit that
button and it opens up a panel kind of
like this that displays all the axes of
variation for a given typeface and
actually builds it right into the tool
so maybe this isn't something that you
want to expose to any author maybe you
actually have a separate role in your
CMS where somebody else is publishing
text and then somebody else in the
design role can go in and do something
specific for say the headline or
promotional blocks that might be sitting
in the sidebar I mean I thought that
might be a really interesting way to go
so I built it I'm gonna show this to you
live in a moment but just in case the
demo completely flames out and want to
show you what's gonna happen so this is
something that I built in Drupal it's
using a couple of the variable fonts
that people have given me to play around
with and that promo block on the right
is one where if you hit edit you can go
in and go into one of these variable
font lines and it exposes all of these
sliders and you save it and you get
something that looks different so that
notion of building up something that is
a little bit more tailored or a little
bit more unique and speaks a little bit
differently with the different cadence
in a different variation is something
that you know in a few hours I sort of
knocked up a proof-of-concept but you
can see where that's going turning it
into more of a plug in approach all it's
doing is writing out a little style
sheet that's it it's really quite simple
so let's take a quick look I think we've
got some time so I'm gonna flip over and
then we'll come back we've got a little
bit more I want to talk about with
regard to support so this is the demo
site that I put together and I'll zoom
in a little bit so you can see things a
little bit better so let's see what's
going on here this is sort of a basic
installation of Drupal 8 so it doesn't
really have any
modules installed there's a couple in
there to support a little bit of this
stuff and then it's a very simple theme
and we've got let's see we've got lavet
from CJ done there
we've got gimlet over there on the right
from David and this one right here that
one I just got today for Microsoft and
that is shipping in Windows 10 this fall
variable font support in the name of
bond shrift is the name of that
particular typeface so let's go into one
of these articles so I'm gonna click on
this link over here and we go in and if
I wanted to make a change here I decide
that really that's way too much emphasis
I'm totally overstating the value of
this individual blog post which is not
uncommon and edit this is the line that
I want to change here's our sliders so
the the width is kind of cranked down a
little bit the weights way up let's just
switch them around and I'll just go
ahead and save that that's a little
different so this isn't huge this isn't
really offering every possible width or
weight or access to variation but the
concept of being able to think through
building the design tools into the
publishing process is really very
accessible now and if we wanted to go in
and edit that again and even change the
typeface if you have and it just made a
select menu that lists them I know what
I have defined in the at font face file
so if I wanted to change it from gimlet
and change it over to one of one another
one of David's options that he gave me
to play with called output sands so
change it again
so that's what I wanted to show working
in the browser but I also want to talk
about the support because this is
something that was completely
experimental 12 months ago it's now
something that is shipping fully
supported here in iOS 11 they shipped
full support for variable fonts built
right into the OS it works in Firefox it
works in Safari Chrome is coming very
shortly so I'm going to flip back over
here for a minute
so our status check on support with this
experimental technology that is really
quite new is remarkably good so it is
available now in iOS it will be baked
into High Sierra when that releases I
think this coming week mid October I've
heard the 17th Chrome will be shipping
with it on by default currently if you
enable web experimental web platform
features it works on both Mac and
Windows and then the edge team and
Firefox I believe I'm not a hundred
percent certain about Firefox the edge
team is committed to supporting at font
face by the end of 2017 and this right
down here is a screen grab from what I
just showed you in Windows 10 it's
currently available in their preview
release that variable font file is
something like 26 K or something like
that I mean it's ridiculously small the
only thing that that one's offering is
weight variation but I can also show you
the access praxis site where it kind of
demonstrates a whole bunch more
and so the CSS syntax is going to be
tied right in to a lot of stuff that we
already work with font weight font
stretch font style
there's also font variation settings
which allows you to access all of them
and there's a bunch of stuff that I've
put up just last week on github that
will give you a whole bunch of sample
pages and then I'm hosting the variable
fonts so that you can play around with
it and
take it for a test drive yourself so we
have links on the right slides previous
versions are already up I'll have these
up as soon as we're done here the code
that link bitly / j pv f demos gets you
a repository of all the sample pages
that i was just talking about a lot of
the moby-dick pages that i was showing
you in here and there you can find out a
little bit more about Tristan and Tilly
if you want to follow me on instagram at
j palm and tell and see their adventures
every morning and i think we've got
about 10 minutes for questions or
showing more demos thank you
[Applause]